It may seem silly to even ask the question,
but can plants think?
Some scientists suggest they do!
Hi guys, Lissette here for DNews.
I know you’re thinking this sounds like
a secret plot to turn you against vegetarians,
but plants have the ability to remember and
process information, and even do things like
count and communicate.
A recent study published in the journal Current
Biology found that venus fly traps track and
remember the number of times an insect touches
the plant’s trigger hairs, or hairlike mechanosensors
in the fly trap’s mouth.
When an insect lands on a venus fly trap and
doesn’t move, this single stimulation will
lead to pretty much nothing.
But if the insect moves a second time within
the next 20 seconds, the venus flytrap will
shut.
On the third movement sensed, the plant will
begin to ooze out digestive acids and the
more the insect moves, the more acid it will
release.
This is significant because it requires the
venus fly trap to hold onto information and
essentially remember the number of times it’s
received a specific stimulus and then respond
appropriately.
If a second movement isn’t detected before
20 seconds, they venus fly trap will essentially
reset.
This helps it differentiate between rain drops,
wind, and an actual meal.
Now, that sounds like one smart plant.
But it’s not alone.
There are a lot of plants out there that can
do some pretty smart things.
In fact, some may be communicating with each
other.
You may have heard your mother tell you to
put that ripe apple by the green ones in order
to ripen them…
well, the reason this works is that when a
fruit like an apple starts to ripen it secretes
a natural plant hormone called ethylene and
other nearby fruits pick up on this and begin
to ripen as well.
Acacia trees seem to communicate in a similar
way too.
When antelope graze on them, acacia trees
also release this chemical and other non-affected
trees pick up on it.
These alerted trees then produce tannins that
make the leaves poisonous to the antelope.
Some plants can even detect these predators
before they bite.
When researchers at the University of Missouri
played sounds of caterpillars munching leaves
to mustard plants, the mustard plants responded
by releasing mustard oil, which is deadly
to caterpillars.
The plants did not respond this way to regular
old wind and other sounds, it was specifically
the sound of caterpillars eating leaves that
caused the mustard plant to defend itself.
With somewhere between 15 and 20 different
senses to absorb and respond to other cues
from their environment, plants can start to
seem almost as smart as some lower animals
- this is what Darwin suggests.
So plants can “hear” predators coming,
“smell” when they’re nearby, count the
number of times their leaves are touched.
And they even seem to get clues from their
neighbors about what’s going on to increase
their chances of surviving.
All these responses and cell to cell communication
are what some scientists go as far as calling,
“intelligent behavior.”
But how smart do plants seem to you?
Have you ever kept one as a pet?
Sound off in the comments below.
And to learn why some plants evolved to eat
animals, check out Julia and Julian’s video
here.Thanks for watching DNews.
Remember to like and subscribe for more videos.
What do you think?
Are plants intelligent?
Or do you absolutely need a brain to be smart?